[Music]
rng just
felt like destiny it felt like you
couldn't deny
what was prophesized rng head to the
grand finals
first time ever rng is chasing success
roy will never give up rule the world
really
2018. have rng ascended to godhood
and did ig miss their chance to actually
beat them
is looking for a flank that's the
curtain call they're pinned into a
narrow corridor look at the damages it
comes across thing looks for entry
they found shintai once again he goes
gold but a true kill for
rookie ridiculous there's still bottom
broke warriors yeah
you can make a play the shots like come
at me let's go i'll take out flawless
anyway
now he's in the one versus one and i'm
not actually feeling enjoy these chances
it comes to dunk
the one versus two they're on to the
nexus they are doing it
they are rewriting the history books and
they will punch in their tickets
to nanjing
firing in the back line one is down and
the baron it doesn't even matter again
it's over
jackie love is taking the series into
his own hands he is firing onto the
nexus
and with him and fix this game he will
not gonna play it
after he's gonna he gets it we've got a
ig and rng are two orgs that have been a
part of the lpl since the very beginning
and on february 7th they'll play their
last regular season match
before the lpl breaks for the lunar new
year a widely televised event in china
known as the esports spring gala now
this match is very important for rng
who might actually be able to contend
for a title again and for ig
who are currently vying for a playoff
spot but
back in 2018 things were very different
at the start of the 2018 lpl spring
season
all eyes were on the old orgs that had
ruled the region
for years edg rng and w.e
had been the lpl's representatives at
worlds and for fans of the lpl
that collection of teams didn't seem out
of place but
one club that had been part of the lpl
from the beginning seemed perpetually
overlooked
invictus gaming even after a third place
finish in the summer playoffs
ig failed to make worlds they had a
world-class mid laner in rookie and
soon to be superstar the shy in top i
think it took
a long time for the shai to finally get
his chance
and to showcase actually how good he was
to the rest of the world and alongside
with rookie
they just flat out had some of the best
talent in the entire league
plus after years of hype building up for
his debut
their adc jackie love had finally joined
the starting roster
jackie love was all that everyone could
have hoped for he was
ultra aggressive he fitted that ig sort
of style and he was a very good ad carry
but still they had never won a
championship
still everyone's focus was elsewhere
but that was all about to change brings
out the less battery in the middle lane
once more rookie will engage underneath
the tower
and find the kill onto your gown the
emacs rookie does so much work they're
still going and looking towards bottom
lane this would have to be a dive though
now the unbreakable will knock him on
the jacket but there are two more
members of invictus gaming that they did
not bank on
dracula counting away the flash force
from rd isn't good enough the stunt from
bow land
saves the 80 carry sejuani finds a kill
on the backside
a jackal of disengages that was
disgusting
an 18-1 record during the regular season
37 wins five losses dominant
overpowering unstoppable however you
want to phrase it
ig's 88 spring win rate still stands as
one of the most
dominant seasons ever jackie love was
quickly turning into a terror in the
bottom lane and
rookie and the shy owned the solo lanes
five to one is the score after another
pick on the ning
not having a good day does get flicked
back here by talia still wants to go
toe-to-toe happy to trade but rookie
might get the better of him
blocks the queue tries to dig this one
up he's going it does pick up that kill
slight burst of damage takes down
shelley that was really really
unfortunate coming out there from bow
land though the shot is looking for a
trade in the top plane uses the ultimate
to dodge the cc coming in from shang now
he's looking for the chase down
damage coming out from the shy unreal
and the shot just adds another solo kill
to his repertoire
by the time the playoffs came around ig
had a direct
seed into the semi-finals and looked
poised to take home
their first lpl title meanwhile the
perennial powerhouse
royal never give up had had a middling
regular season
but this split was about more than a
title for rng
it was about
[Music]
was one of the greatest players ever to
touch the game but
like ig he'd never won an lpl title they
boasted a powerful roster
designed to do the same thing uzi's
teams had always tried to do
feed the puppy
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
but they faced their greatest obstacle
in the semi-finals
invictus gaming fortunately for them the
shy
was out with a hand injury 100 i think
the shy being out there
was definitely a huge boon to rng's
chances
rng has always been this team that
played around their bottom side their
top lane
basically rolled over and gave the
opponent whatever
they wanted rng definitely dodged a
bullet with that one and again they
moved from buff to buff
now on the red buff but it's gonna be
[ __ ] with the initiation looking
knocked back out she but he doesn't get
it
misses the ultimate crucial coil down
and the choo choo trains in the back
lines everyone's low
everyone from ig is just gonna get taken
down triple kill being picked up by uzi
chasing down the fourth quarter duke's
the only one left alone
decided to go for a prolonged fight
doesn't work out well for ig
yeah ning was pretty much doing that for
temple but i'm not sure what jackie love
is doing here
what step stop step aside doctor is
respect because uzi he does not lose
diaper fights
takes down jackie love legs now in
trouble as well rg
pedal to the floor going straight
forward taking down ig jackie love gonna
get
kyle controlled by xiaohu final
inhibitor is going to fall uzi looking
for the fight chase crosstalk is
spreading they got in the back lines
jackie left
there's bees coming bees everywhere the
tyre runs lamps around the nexus
but it doesn't matter because one by one
invictus gaming members will
fall they're one step closer and when
they're next to this party jackie love
was not able to be the hero of this
league he could not stand up to uzi
rng head to the grand finals it was a
close series but
in the end ig just couldn't handle rng
they had dominated the regular season
but they'd done it off the backs of
their individual stars
and with one of those stars injured they
simply couldn't match rng's strengths in
a best of five
and for uzi the rest of the playoffs
were his coronation
can you hear that uzi can taste it his
team
are trying to pull him over the line and
even the crowd knows let me watch it now
knock this going in and the egg
using the status but he's gonna go down
as well uzi picks up a double and
there's only one member left and it's
reign
all they need to do now is dot the irons
cross the t's rng
they have set themselves up to win where
were you
when history was made because here comes
uzi the curse
lifted the prophecy has been fulfilled
uzi now reigns as king
royal never give up champions
and it didn't stop there uzi wasn't done
look at the death timers it's 40 seconds
on bdd it's 33
on prey peanuts trying to cut the wave
the inhibitor
is the focus and now is peanut ragnarok
to try and escape the inhibitor will
fall middle
there goes levi's soul it's caught up by
khan khan
he's got the ultimate available gorilla
he's not gonna be able to save him
and kings for the first time
ever rng is chasing success roy will
never
give up rule the world really get inside
2018.
i'll always have that moment seared in
my mind when they finally
realize that they have become
international champions and they
shoot up from their chairs and they
can't even believe that
even with such a dominant second half of
the tournament that they were finally
going to make it they were finally going
to redeem themselves
it wasn't the lpl's first msi title edg
won the first msi in 2015
but this time it was different this
wasn't a blip
in the era of korean dominance it wasn't
an astounding but
momentary peak at victory the lpl had
toppled the lck in the most recent
all-stars and royals finals against the
ascendant
king zone proved less competitive than
their domestic showdown against ig
this msi was crucial it was different
it was the moment that fans started to
believe
now ig might have been sidelined during
rng's historic run at msi
and in many ways the summer regular
season was a mirror
for the spring the shy was back and ig
were still monsters i'll take out
flawless anyway
now he's in the one versus one and i'm
not actually feeling enjoyed these
chances
here comes that dunk the one versus two
the shy looks to death his beady eyes he
spits in them
ming is looking for a flank that's the
curtain call they're pinned into a
narrow corridor look at the damages it
comes across ning looks for entry
they found shintai once again he goes
golden buttercream kill for
rookie another 18 in one season this
time with a
modest 76 win rate across all their
games
put ig at the top of their group but
still
there were cracks in that reflection
they split their matches against the
reigning champions
and even if rng cruised to a less
dominant 14-5
the summer finals felt like fate
ig's brute force was enough to
obliterate another regular season
their solo laners were unparalleled
jockey loves debut transcendent
in his first year of pro play he was
second only
to uzi but rng were more than a team
more than players they were destiny
incarnate
rng just felt like destiny it felt like
you couldn't deny
what was prophesized because they were
on the golden road
with a golden logo and they were playing
feed the puppy
in the year of the dog no scriptwriter
could have done it better
and when it came time for the finals the
first two games of the series looked
like uzi's reign
would continue rng were able to get uzi
comfortably ahead each time and despite
ig's talented laners it didn't seem like
they had an
answer but in game 3 that talent shone
through
and by game 4 there were visible cracks
in rng's mental fortitude
and they're starting to sweat bullets
let me just switch to smite that is what
they're looking at right now they are
trying to make the play because they
have to make this play
if they lose the baron buff the game is
over as the super minions crash
ning has flashed his smite is about
there foreign
and that's jackie love going for the
back door rng turn onto the bearing
shiny love is firing in the back line
one is down and the baron it doesn't
even matter
it's over
[Applause]
and after an underwhelming fourth game
rng made the risky decision to sub in
the talented but famously inconsistent
mlxg
in jungle but what's that it's not
caster in the jungle it's mlxg they just
decided all right
let's bring out mlxg or go for that type
of victory room going against invictus
gaming
with mlxg subbed in on his signature
knock turn
rng had one way to secure their second
consecutive lpl title
they had to take the fight to the
ultimate fighters
target is jackie love lands the fear
ning going low change of corruption
misses
he's still tiring they get the damage on
to nick jackie looks sidesteps the
knock-up but the one
that walks in jack he loves still firing
oozie chases him down and gets himself
the kill uzi
with a double rookie forced to run as
the arrows missed the flash exhaust and
who's he wants it
who's he will get it a triple kill to
the mad dog
let me even walking up the river on the
bottom side from the dragon
he's gonna be an old ranger knock
they found the paranoia stun is ready
but they've left thing behind he flashes
back the diamond in the back
bowling and jackie lover the targets and
they go down uzi is free firing the shy
tries to stand tall but the guardian
angel will be popped here beyond death
he dives in as rookie finds a blast but
mlxg
survives there's no way he teleports to
go back
in there too much to deal with to shy
one man against an army one man against
all of china
cannot hold his ground it dies in rng
today they sat down as players
but after this they will rise as
kings long may they raid
royal never give up for your 2018
lpl champions
and karsa especially was overcome
parsa obviously felt like he let the
team down but rng
members they they went around karsa and
they let him actually lift the cup
alongside with uzi
of course there was one tournament left
to play and while many analysts pegged
royal as favorites to win the event
there was also serious competition from
the lck
so even after one of the strongest years
in ig's history
they found themselves in a familiar
position underrated
and overlooked sure they were strong but
they clearly had holes in their play but
league of legends had begun to change
the world's meta featured some of the
strongest carry champions the game had
ever seen it was a meta designed for
individual carries
sculpted to shape superstars
ig we're home keep my ning is alive
but somebody's going to find himself the
slow the giant knockout i'm not going to
found his belt
into the back side the double kill for
rookie
and will it be more the third looking
for the fourth they're trying to run
away
and poor someday can only walk that
flash not gonna go too far
not gonna be an easy answer body slam
again in a three
versus five ig find four
kills but health bars at half on some
critical members means it might not be
as important as it looks
shaw's gonna take some damage look he
looks to go in does get the passive pop
shy's still gonna be soaking root comes
down damage goes through jackie's
able to find two jackie love just found
everybody and that's gonna be a triple
for ig
they're gonna find everyone it's kt ace
the most people on now gonna be the
target of the vanguard's edge
wonder trying to make something happen
but g2 looks like they just want to
disengage this one now
they've already got the pick onto the
enemy jumper oh
so many people that's the aatrox damage
and the shy makes it happen meanwhile
rng made it out of their group in first
but in the end they fell short of the
perfect year after a shocking
upset to g2 denying fans the rematch
against ig
no there's the engagement just entered
such
they may have just done it g2 have just
dismantled rng
and they're gonna make their way to the
semifinals
one by one the favorites fell and ig
were ready to make history roxanne
reckless versus the world
reckless goes on a rampage but ning is
still there pressuring onto the turret
with the rest of ig reckless is down
bronx is away ig are on the nexus
the lpl has never won before but that
will change today
the groundless are finally king and
infect this gaming
are your 2018 world champions
as ig hoisted the trophy they became the
first
non-korean champions since 2012 the
first modern team
ever capable of besting the lck
times had changed for good in the season
since 2018 ig and rng have never been as
competitive at the same time
as they were but their momentary rivalry
at that time
in that year changed everything
2018 was the end of the era of korean
dominance
and it was the start of a new era the
moment the lpl began to be recognized as
the world's most competitive region
and when rng and ig step onto the stage
for the spring gala
or any series to come they carry that
history with them
they remind us of an era when anything
was possible
a time when heroes became kings
everything they worked for everything
they did how far they've come
this is the culmination of all that hard
work for the entire team
this is a series you look at and say ig
show to everyone
how you play league of legends in 2018.
you